Oxford Dictionary has come out with its
list of words and phrases that the
editors say are likely to stand the test
of time I'm not sure I necessarily agree
with this but you decide you ready for
this one one of the new entries Yolo as
in you only live once the view that
should make the most of the present it's
carpe diem carpe diem Yolo apparently
that is now a timeless word here's
another one amazeballs I feel like I
ought to be saying this like
what's-his-name amazeballs baby what was
his name come on you know I Myers yeah
Mike Myers was clown what's the
character come on help me out Austin
Powers Thank You Austin Powers did he
say amazeballs I don't know but it
sounds like you got to amaze balls the
definition is just extremely good or
impressive as listicle made it yet
listicle yes was on the list which I
find uh what is the Melissa what is the
definition it's it's any list of items
that people should combined with an
article yeah yes what should be watching
more but is it fair to say that word
very closely three four times in a row
all right here's another one through
from this in the Oxford Dictionary hot
mess believe that hot mess no I can't
believe I'm I don't know why Oxford's
doing this don't get a desecration of
English language is what your vape I can
almost get two because it's sort of out
there but have you think I just think
they're under a lot of pressure to be
hip and current and they're you know
doing